there is a deep geopolitical connection
between the United States and that part
of the world what is the role of us
politicians in all of
this you know James
Baldwin uh wrote about how Israel was
created as an extension of United States
policy to be a colonial entity at the
gates of the Middle East and to function
essentially as a military base out there
and as a means of of extending its
policy um you know throughout the Middle
East and it has functioned as such the
United States is not an honest peace
broker it never has been an honest peace
broker the United States uh has never
shown any uh meaningful inclination
towards peace has guarded and protected
Israel from International accountability
has made Israel in Invincible the United
States is not just responsible at the
governmental level
for the genocide it's responsible for
letting it get to this point in the
first place we have
funded that Arsenal we've given them the
most sophisticated weapons in the world
to test
on the most desperate population in the
world we've given them the
weapons it's been bipartisan
we have issued at most inconsequential
statements of
condemnation but at the same time
stopped any International body of law
from actually holding it accountable so
the United States at this point um
unfortunately has rightfully lost all
credibility it should remove
itself uh from this because it is not an
honest peace broker I think Americans
are probably sick of us paying for Wars
in general en I think Americans are
probably sick of our tax dollars going
to funding a genocide while we have a
rise of homelessness and um income
disparity here in the United States I
think that Americans probably don't like
that we're making
ourselves uh so deeply unpopular in the
world because of Israel's actions so in
the immediate moment make this stop the
United States could have had a SE fire a
long time ago the United States could
have ended this genocide right
away the reason why this is
continuing is because of US foreign
policy and in the process of Joe Biden
talking about managing this crisis and
talking about making things better there
have only been more bills that have come
out of Congress in fact he's bypassed
Congress to fund the Arsenal to keep
replenishing the Arsenal stop paying for
weapons stop paying for for someone
else's war crimes stop protecting
another country as it commits these war
crimes and if you can't be an honest
peace broker get out of the process so
there's money that you just mentioned
and bills and then there's rhetoric
which you also
criticized that he spoke about the
behead of
babies and things of that nature so
where has uh Joe Biden fallen short yeah
we need another podcast that's going to
take a few hours to talk about where Joe
Biden has failed um for one the first
time he seemed to find the word
Palestinian in his vocabulary was when
he accused the Palestinians of lying
about the death toll uh in Gaza and then
that turned out to also be false in fact
the numbers that were coming out of the
Gaza Health Ministry according to
multiple International bodies have been
Under reporting Palestinian casualty
counts Israeli intelligence has said
that the civilian count or the death
toll is actually higher than what's been
coming out of the Gaza Health Ministry
so he's failed on that front he has
failed to speak to Palestinian Humanity
he has spoken with deep passion and
concern as has Anthony blinkin about you
know the devastation in Israel and the
way that people are feeling in Israel
and has shown nothing of that sort
towards Palestinians we don't want the
rhetoric we really don't want the
rhetoric uh you know when people say
call for a
ceasefire the United States has had an
opportunity and has an opportunity to to
really walk back and reflect on its
entire
policy towards Israel Palestine this is
a moment of reflection this is a moment
of restoration if you want it to be
right and to think about what we've
enabled in the first place he's shown
absolutely no real empathy um
and I think that he is under great
delusion and thinking that um the Muslim
Community or people of conscience are
going to forgive this are going to
forget this come November you can't tell
us that well at least I don't have the
Trump Muslim ban while also carrying out
a genocide primarily against Muslims and
think that the Muslims are still going
to vote for you and so we will make him
hear us at the polls and any
politician uh for Congress or otherwise
that has not called for a ceasefire that
has been a part of this
dehumanization we will make sure that we
seee support for them in any way as a
community it's only right so Biden has
lost or is losing the hearts and the
support of the
Muslim Palestinian people and the uh
Muslim people in America I don't know if
he ever had the hearts of the Muslim
Community to be honest with you I mean I
personally was never a Joe Biden fan and
I think a lot of people felt the same
you know this country unfortunately
leads to the uh the way that our
political system is built is that you're
always voting for the lesser of the two
evils that's always the way that is it's
analyzing which evil is lesser right and
when people say if you vote for Donald
Trump and I'm not planning to vote for
Donald Trump either but if you don't
vote for Joe Biden right if you don't
vote for Jo Joe Biden right then you are
destroying democracy I'm like a
democracy that's given us a choice
between Donald Trump and Joe Biden is
already fa democracy and so he he never
had the hearts and minds of the Muslim
Community uh people always saw past his
rhetoric he always has had a terrible
disposition towards Palestine he's
always had a terrible disposition
towards the Muslim World um you know his
his segregationist past comes out
sometimes when he starts talking about
the Muslim world and and you can hear
the racism in his voice and you can hear
the way that he talks about uh
Palestinian life um in such devalued
fashion so
he lost us uh a long time ago but he's
definitely not getting us back after
this in any way and I can't speak for
all Muslims but I think that come
November uh he and all of those
politicians especially in swing states
that have turned their backs on the
Muslim Community and not just the Muslim
Community by the way 67% of this country
wants a ceasefire 34s of democratic
voters want a ceasefire half of
Republican voters want a ceasefire right
it's not just the Muslim Community this
is not some radical opinion to call for
a ceasefire and every single politician
that has refused to hear us is going to
pay a price at the polls as they should
that doesn't mean that we're under any
illusion that the other side promises us
anything better in fact it it sound it
feels like Republicans have simply
rushed to out racist the Democrats to
outpace them in terms of talking about
how they're going to be more
Unapologetic in supporting Israel
unconditionally right like it's it's
been
pathetic
um but something has to change and I
think that Americans of
conscience have to look at how this
failed political system has hurt people
here and abroad and talk about how to
transcend that with just more Humanity
again when you have 67% of the American
public that wants a ceasefire but only a
handful of congressmen
out of over 500 can muster up the
courage in the face of these super packs
to say that you know uh we should stop
the genocide right and it's like what
are you asking for here you're asking
for the genocide to stop you're asking
for Israeli hostages to be brought home
you're asking for Palestinian prisoners
to be released you're asking for peace
and to start carving the path out to end
this once and for all right in the most
ambiguous way possible by the way
because there aren't many radical
American politicians right it's it's the
way that the system is in the most
ambiguous way possible and you can't
even bring yourself to do that this is
already a failed democracy then all the
while again you know it always boggles
my mind if you're from the America First
crew what's America First about uh
funling billions and billions and
billions of dollars to Israel while it
carries out this genocide while people
are starving here and if you're part of
the human rights crew and you know
Progressive crew it's you know they have
a term called Progressive except
Palestine right P Progressive except
Palestine where are all your Notions of
social justice you talk about policing
here but you don't talk about who trains
our police departments and many major
cities and the type of brutality that's
being carried out there you talk about
human rights at the border here but you
don't talk about the assault on people
at the border there you talk about all
of these things here but you somehow use
the exact same framings against the
people there so it's it's exposed I
think the moral
bankruptcy of both political Polar
Opposites that exist in this country
right now and
hopefully evoked a greater societal
sentiment to say this is
ridiculous you know one of the things
that is happening is that more people
are getting their news outside of Legacy
Media
Outlets you can't hide that many any
dead babies anymore you just can't more
people have woken up to the Palestinian
plight now than ever before more people
are outraged that this has been our
American foreign policy all throughout
you know uh Democratic and Republican
administrations this is what we've been
paying for this is what we've been
excusing and Israeli leaders literally
spit in the faces of whoever the
American president is and says yeah we
don't care what they tell us to do you
know American leadership says we're
pushing Israel to minimize the the
casualties to to get less indiscriminate
with its bombing to manage the crisis
get a few more humanitarian corridors in
to make sure that that Gaza is not
evacuated and not ethnically cleansed to
make sure Palestinians can come back and
Netanyahu comes on TV and says from The
River To The Sea how ironic is that from
The River To The Sea and that is his
policy we're going to make sure that
Israel controls from The River To The
Sea and we're going to push Palestinians
into
Sinai and Muslim countries need to take
them in you have Israeli ministers
National Defense ministers saying you
know things openly right like we want to
thin out the population I.E ethnic
cleansing we want to remove people and
the Muslim world needs to step up and
take in these refugees right and the
American Administration you know or the
American president says and American
Secretary of State says you know we're
talking to them and we're making sure
that that's not going to happen and if
one of their ministers says something
blinkin maybe tweets out something about
how that's not going to happen but then
it happens anyway and then we still
write them the checks so I think most of
the American public is probably going to
get sick of this at some point just
people of decency and people of
conscience are going to say yeah this is
not something we want to be a part of
anymore do you think there's something
that Donald Trump can
do to help move this in the right
direction Trump's first words were about
how he's going to be worse uh on this
right so he talked about how he's going
to deport people uh revoke visas of uh
you know
students that are part of these Pro
Palestinian rallies Al the focus was on
the rallies versus what's going on
abroad yeah but look we had a Donald
Trump presidency he moved the embassy to
Jerusalem he was not better on this uh
unfortunately this is a bipartisan
problem and so again we're under No
Illusion here like we're not looking to
Donald Trump as a savior here but we are
going to penalize Joe Biden and that's
you know I can't speak for everybody but
I think that that's where a lot of our
minds are at right
now